by now i'm sure you're all familiar with
the bitcoin and ethereum the two most
popular cryptocurrencies in the world
the founder or founders of bitcoin have
chosen to remain anonymous and though
there's a lot of speculation as to who
might have founded bitcoin the only
thing that we know for sure is that the
founder goes by the elias satoshi
nakamoto on the other hand we know the
founder of ethereum it's a guy named
vitalik buterin unlike all the
contenders for satoshi nakamoto vitalik
isn't some 50 or 60 year old
mathematician or programmer in fact
vitalik is only 27 years old today
vitalik first entered the crypto scene
at 17 he proposed ethereum at 19 and he
launched the darn thing at 21.
today vitalik is the world's youngest
crypto billionaire and he's already
donated over one billion dollars to
charity
so here's the story of the child prodigy
behind ethereum
taking a look back metallic was born on
january 31 1994 in colombia russia he
lived a lot of his early childhood in
russia but most of his formative years
were in canada as his family moved there
when vitalik was six from very early on
it was clear that vitalik wasn't an
ordinary child in third grade vitalik
was accepted into a program for gifted
students
and many of his teachers were surprised
by how talented vitalik was in math and
programming
unfortunately it looks like metallic
fell into the stereotype of being a nerd
that was not very social vitalik really
took part in social gatherings and
extracurricular events something that
vitalik was heavily involved in though
was world of warcraft between 2007 and
2010 world of warcraft was vitalik's
favorite way to enjoy his free time
there's often a lot of stigma
surrounding gaming as it's seen as a
waste of time that offers little to no
real life value
however for vitalik world of warcraft
was actually a thing that would
introduce him to the crypto space the
story goes then in 2010 blizzard the
developers of wow removed the damage
component of italic's beloved warlock
siphon life spell this change made
vitalik extremely upset and he says that
he cried himself to sleep that night for
the first time vitalik realized the
downfalls of a centralized system this
distraught eventually introduced vitalik
to the cryptocurrency space the
following year when metallic was first
introduced to bitcoin he says that he
was quite skeptical like most of us his
primary concern with bitcoin was that it
didn't have any physical backing how
could nothing have value
but as vitalik looked more into cryptos
he realized that the same argument could
be made against fiat currencies as well
at 17 vitalik got a job writing for a
bitcoin magazine called bitcoin weekly
he was only paid 1.50 cents per hour but
given that vitalik wasn't in it for the
money he was okay with it
also something that should be noted was
that vitalik was paid in bitcoin the
owner of the magazine paid him five
bitcoins per article which was only
worth 3.50 at the time
this means that vitalik was roughly paid
2.1 for bitcoins per hour
in hindsight i think we'd all agree that
this wasn't bad at all
unfortunately bitcoin weekly eventually
shut down due to insufficient revenue
but by the time the publication closed
vitalik was able to build a name for
himself in the crypto space thus when a
crypto enthusiast named mihai elisi
started his own bitcoin publication
vitalik was one of his top choices
mikhail asked vitalik to co-found
bitcoin magazine with him and become the
magazine's lead writer
and with that vitalik would launch his
first business in september of 2011 at
age 17.
this was nearly a full-time job for
vitalik as he would spend 30 hours per
week researching crypto writing about
crypto and working on other crypto
projects despite putting so much effort
into crypto vitalik didn't drop the ball
on school either
vitalik continued to be a top performer
in high school and he even won a bronze
medal in the international olympiad in
informatics in 2012.
after high school vitalik enrolled in
the university of waterloo but in
college crypto would start to consume
his life he was traveling around the
world to meet with crypto experts and
write about their perspectives and
outlooks in his magazine as he met with
all these crypto experts vitalik started
to notice a common set of complaints and
pitfalls regarding crypto projects
most cryptos were built for specific use
cases and were not very applicable
outside of their niches
vitalik felt that the shortfall could
easily be fixed by replacing the current
protocols with the touring complete
programming language vitalik proposed
his idea to all of the existing projects
that he had built relationships with but
none of them were really interested in
the idea
so metallic decided to do it himself in
late 2013 vitalik wrote about his idea
for ethereum in a white paper which he
shared with his crypto friends his
crypto friends then shared it with their
friends and in no time a large portion
of the crypto community was talking
about the potential of ethereum the
positive feedback was super encouraging
but vitalik wasn't quite ready to make
the jump yes he owned a business and he
probably had dozens of bitcoin but this
wasn't really worth that much at the
time
in an effort to get some funding vitalik
would apply to the theo fellowship which
awards 100 000 to young people who want
to quote build new things instead of
sitting in a classroom and sure enough
vitalik would win the 100 thousand
dollars but this was nothing in
comparison to how much they were about
to race
vitalik mihai gavin wood and a couple of
other crypto enthusiasts started work on
ethereum in january of 2014. one month
later vitalik revealed the buffed up
version of ethereum at the 2014 bitcoin
conference and a few months later the
team would hold an initial coin offering
to raise more money for the project i'm
not sure how much money they were
looking to raise but it looks like they
crushed their ico the team ended up
raising a whopping 18 million dollars by
selling 31 000 bitcoins worth of ether
i don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that vitalik dropped out of college
after this outstanding funding round
over the next year the team developed
the bulk of ethereum and the platform
would officially launch in july of 2015.
now it should be noted that ethereum
itself is actually just a platform the
cryptocurrency that people generally
refer to as ethereum is actually called
ether anyway while there was a lot of
hype surrounding ethereum's launch it
didn't take long for obstacles to arise
as well with the first major hurdle
being the dow attack in 2016 a
decentralized autonomous organization or
dao raised money in order to create a
venture capital firm based on ethereum
this was one of the most hyped projects
at the time
in fact it was so hyped that 14 of all
ethereum circulation was invested into
the dow
this translated to roughly 150 million
dollars
less than three months after its launch
though the dial would be hacked and 60
million dollars was stolen a code
exploit and the dow's wallet smart
contracts could be leveraged to drain
the funds in the dow's wallet this was a
life-threatening issue as this massive
security issue cast out on ethereum as a
whole
it's very possible that ethereum could
have gone down with the dow attack but
vitalik was determined to prevent this
from happening at first vitalik proposed
a soft fork with the soft fork
previously valid transaction blocks
could be made invalid
but battalion needed the support of the
majority of miners in order to complete
the fork successfully after hearing
about this plan the hackers fired back
claiming that it's not their fault that
there was a security issue and the funds
they stole were quote-unquote obtained
through fair means the hackers
threatened that they would bribe miners
using one million ethereum and prevent a
soft fork from being completed as a
result metallic was forced to consider a
hard fork a hard fork is when a
substantial change is made to a
blockchain network and miners and users
have the option of following the
original path or the new path metallic
could reimburse the investors using
tokens on the new protocol but this was
extremely controversial cryptocurrencies
were supposed to be free of a central
authority and a hard fork would clearly
violate this principle nonetheless
metallic executed the hard fork on july
20th 2016 and this is why there are two
major theorem tokens today ethereum
classic or etc and ether or eth
this allowed metallic to return all the
money that was stolen to the investors
using the new eth token
the hackers retained control of the etc
coins they stole but given that everyone
was dumping edc their stake had watered
down to 8.5 million dollars that's still
quite a substantial amount but i don't
think vitalik could have really handled
the situation any better
since then metallic has tried to be more
proactive with updates to ethereum and
that brings us into the latest
development ethereum 2.0 ethereum 2.0 is
designed to reduce energy consumption
transaction costs and transaction speeds
of ethereum the key to accomplishing
this is switching from the proof of work
model to the proof of stake model i have
a full video explaining the difference
between these two protocols and why the
proof of stake model is superior but in
essence the proof of work model is when
miners buy a crop ton of equipment and
try to verify transactions through brute
force this method not only requires a
significant amount of energy but most of
the energy used among crypto is wasted
on brute force
in contrast in a proof of stake model
transactions are verified by individuals
who own a large amount of the given
crypto the idea is that these people
will be truthful while verifying the
transactions given that they wouldn't
want to sabotage their own investment
people who try to abuse the system will
either be fined or even banned from
staking again depending on the severity
of their violation by switching to proof
of stake ethereum will be able to
eliminate the large energy consumption
required for mining ethereum 2.0 first
phases already started rolling out in
december of 2020 but the full transition
isn't expected till sometime in 2022
many people think that ethereum 2.0 will
be the catalyst that propels ether ahead
of bitcoin in terms of market cap but
only time will tell how that plays out
as for vitalik today we don't exactly
know what all of his crypto stakes are
but his net worth is estimated to be
somewhere between 1 billion dollars and
3 billion dollars which makes him the
world's youngest crypto billionaire
vitalik hasn't been shy when it comes to
sharing his wealth either for example in
may metallic donated 1.14 billion worth
of chiba coins to india's covered relief
fund with that type of heart i think
vitalik more than deserves all the
success he's enjoyed so far
do you guys think ether will overtake
bitcoin comment that down below
also drop a like if you're bullish on
cryptocurrencies long term
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you